well second start for matt harvey second
start against the red sox a lot of
people look at that as a difficult task
and it can be because they you know they
just scored 26 runs in the three games
against tampa bay up in boston here's
verdugo
gonna go the other way that's a fair
ball down the line inside out swing he's
off to the races heading into second
base and he is in there sliding with the
double so one out double and here comes
jd martinez is anybody on earth hotter
than jd martinez
so who would buy him
95.
martinez yeah we didn't see 95 up in
boston
rafael devers 2 for 19 to start his
season
high fly ball that one driven into right
center field that's way back there and
she is gone way up into the seats the
red sox jump out in front two to nothing
rafael devers crushing one for his first
home run of 2021. finally got to a
fastball been swinging and missing that
high fastball all year long but he
doesn't miss this one the o2 pitch
lunging at that one that's a fair ball
past the diving ruiz down the line
vasquez into second base and the red sox
have their third extra base head to the
first inning and the beat goes on for
vasquez full count runners at second and
third now two down
harvey delivers
and he got him
arroyo doesn't like the call red sox
down they get two two nothing boston
first start of the season first start in
18 months for the left-hander edward
rodriguez boy it's been a long long time
lefty on lefty in cedric mullins
along with the strike and he rips
there's another hit make it 13.
solid single to right field
and now here comes trey mancini
[Music]
yeah very gracious
now the red sox which is out in front of
the plate
give the fans the opportunity
and every red sox on the infield
slapping their glove uh cheering for
trey mancini wow that's pretty special
mullins on at first of course he can run
that one is smack the third a sprawling
play by devers got the outed second on
to first safe there
outstanding effort there headlong dive
nice play to get there you got to get it
out of your glove
mullins is out easily a second they try
to turn it anyway which is fairly close
santander will be next the right fielder
2-2
got him came up the ladder and he struck
him out his first k since the return
ryan meltcastle coming up to the plate
mancini down at first two down
that's it well
deep right center field way back
it's out of here
how about that his first opening day in
baltimore ryan montcastle
smokes one out of here and we are tied
at two freddie galvez to step in man the
lefty with the o2 pitch
and a swing and a miss to get him but
he's roughed up for a couple of runs two
outs and [ __ ] hernandez stepping to the
plate the kick the one-two
breaking ball pounded on the ground at
third ruiz has got it tosses across the
diamond and hernandez gone harvey does
just that as he bounces back in the
second next guy up might be
the only other guy right now in jd
martinez class of being a hot hitter and
that's cedric mullins
going up the middle but right there is
gonzales to set him down good inning for
eduardo good recovery one two three they
go
the modern defenses go
bad there great pitch this is a slider
that he threw jd who's red hot
just don't pick up the spin swing over
it vazquez with another double in the
first inning just on fire
line and another hit for vasquez all the
way to the warning track
martinez heading into third and this is
going to be another extra base hit for
christian vasquez that's his second
double today
crawling two strikes
bounced down to first mancini sticks
with it nice play flips to harvey and
the orioles retire the red sox santander
is over one with a k
swag and a miss he sets down santander
for the second time mount castle to
climb in
up the middle
on to first base and plenty of time and
it's a one two three again for the sox
left-hander
harvey delivers the one-two pitch got
him looking
two down
nice pitch by matt harvey
pedro severino digs in here's the pitch
right field that's deep perdugal back
back running out of room it's gone
severino gives the orioles the lead
with the second homer of the game for
the birds
and just a fast ball out over the plate
they had it well directed because if
it's about about 10 feet to the right it
hits the upside out there
here's rio ruiz
got him way inside
let's hope he's all right
up on the forearm somewhere yeah the
two-seam fastball lefty the lefty very
effective yep that's the under
side of that left that back arm brandon
hyde has just been tossed he's just been
tossed as he stands on that first base
line he didn't swing at that ball
trying to get out of the way well you
know what now that i go back and look at
it close right yeah yeah he did swing i
think you know brandon he's just
defended his player a 3-2 pitch
and that's in there for strike three
ruiz pretty ticked off as he flips the
bat
over two for kk hernandez
fly ball
short center field mullins coming hard
makes the diving catch
look where he is look how far he has to
come all the way to there
and matt harvey says thank you very much
02.
you get him yes he did down goes jd
martinez nice inning harvey gets him one
two three
his 77th pitch
cut on and missed he put him away he
strikes out mullins
punch to short and a bobble he recovered
gonzalez yep dalbeck hangs onto the bag
and gets the out nice play by bobby
dalbeck and that retires the side
they are loaded up with nobody out
high chop first base side the pitcher
will flip on to get the out there as the
run comes in to score and the red sox
have tied it up vasquez down to third
second rbi of the season for christian
arroyo and now cordero
that's a shot
out to left mount castle it drops in
from base hit vasquez is in the score
and an aaron toss
all the way to the backstop that means
cordero goes all the way to second base
and the red sox have the lead 4-3
and cordero hit that one still yeah
mount castle's just frozen out there in
left field he didn't even move on this
ball so two gone top of the order and
[ __ ] hernandez quiet day so far for kiki
oh no gets away
oh now they got the runner hung up
there's the flip now they'll come home
mancini makes the tag and the orioles
are out of the inning
jd today one for three
it's that one on the nose and no one's
gonna get it it's all the way to the
warning track that'll chase in another
run verdugo will score
and they change places martinez in the
second 5-3 boston 12 rbis already for jd
martinez oh you're not going to throw jd
a fastball middle middle he stings it
sucks could really put a hurt on
armstrong and the orioles with a hit
here
lashed out and a base hit into left
field
here comes martinez rounding he is in to
score and the red sox are on the board
again
marwin gonzalez goes the other way
beautifully to make it six to three
hernandez hits the ball on the ground
three times he's also flied out over
four
high fly ball down the line that is deep
headed for that wall and that ball is
out of here
[ __ ] hernandez his first home run of the
season
a solo shot here in the eighth inning
red sox with a 7-3 lead here in
baltimore
here's galveston one-two
miss struck him out he just motored
through the night then the red sox went
again
and that
is four straight
and they knock off the orioles here in
game one